police say they have a new lead in their
hunt for a notorious paedophile and
killer who terrorized Melbourne in the
late 80s and early 90s they've never
found the man they call mr. cruel who is
believed to have murdered 13 year-old
Carmen Chan and attacked at least three
other schoolgirls
there's no time o clock hey everybody
it's episode 106 yeah this one's a
request from somebody in Australia I
think what it actually several several
people have requested this topic
the Australian boogeyman the uncaught
rapist and killer mr. crow mr. crow yeah
yeah you told me about this one yeah
this is very like I said this has been
requested at least five times not more
he's abducting girls yeah there's
something that I didn't know a lot about
so it's kind of like a fascinating case
so kind of similar to original night
stocker golden state killer
you know mo yeah kind of a takeover
abduction you break into the house you
take the little girl from the parents he
runs off with her for a couple days and
gives her back yeah most of the time but
yeah so that is our topic for today and
if you are watching us on YouTube or on
one of our other video channels you will
see that we have a green screen type
thing in the back yeah we don't know
what's going on we're experimenting with
the green screen for all I know it looks
like you know some kind of big nebula or
big look like some kind news better
thank God I think that'd be the although
I like the nebula idea okay I might put
some space and shadow no we're still at
we're still [ __ ] around with it
we had to put it in the dryer and like
[ __ ] tape it to the wall may not work
you might just see a green yeah so I'm
just worrying you ahead if you just saw
a green then that means I couldn't find
a good enough background or white and
that thing's tough man it's not like at
least you know when we're looking at it
on our little monitor here it always
looks pale green and you put enough
light on it it doesn't become vibrant it
just whites out yeah I don't know what's
good or not like you know we did a
little pilot rabbit we did we did a
pilot run on it yesterday though and it
came out okay but there was some
pixelation around the edges of my face
yeah and that's so much Brown your face
for some reason I don't I don't know why
I must have been the angle because I'm a
higher definition once again we have to
go to work we're working right now into
the middle of the day we have to drink
terrible it's a weekend for us got
drinking there was a little bit of
confusion because um I think some people
thought ever since we went to the video
forum and I think some people thought we
do these live like on YouTube like yeah
they're not live now we usually record
them the weekend prior right - that's
putting them up so for us it's Saturday
or Sunday so we're not you know like
drinking well sometimes we're drinking
yes so what time you guys see us uh be
two days old already so you know work
from home so we can do what we want yeah
we didn't want anybody like thinking
that we were just drinking every day
although we do now it doesn't work I'm
running with Google car yeah you are
I just have this is like a very good buy
at the vodka and pineapple orange juice
yeah we went out and bought some more
that Welsh's mixed juices yeah yeah like
six half gallons I tried everything I
put there's a dragon fruit mango I tried
that with Kela it was okay passion fruit
you know in South America we know that
it's Monica ja but they have passion
fruit with tequila that worked I still
think the pineapple guava with tequila
works the best though that's just well
guava tequila's something about that
guava tequila that agave and guava kind
of
works okay just takes the tastes it
tastes Central American to me yeah yeah
and you know you know yeah yeah all
right so let's do our little shout outs
now you guys faceless bill and volume 2
yep
the writing of it is [ __ ] done but
it's done and it's huge
I finished the last chapter yesterday
and this book is huge it's like 850
pages at least no no no it's um actually
750 750 well but it still it's like
twice as long almost twice as long as
the first volume yeah and I left a bunch
of stuff out like I had to you because
it was I was just like this is just
getting ridiculous I'm never gonna
finish it gonna be a massive so I had to
like take out a bunch of cases because I
was just like I can't so I pasted it
into the template that I have to do the
the print layout and it's already 756
pages
massive book and yeah and it's still and
I haven't really forum it's gonna be a
good seller though and I still need to
put an index in and [ __ ] like that but
notice that the longer a book is the
more it sells well you go buy big books
you feel like you're getting your
money's worth it's like you're gonna pay
for something it's like you want
something that's gonna give you a while
of enjoying that audiobook is gonna be
like days of entertainment somebody buys
that well like you're honest if you're
on a commute you'd be able to get an
entire week out of it yeah I think the
first faceless villain the audiobook I
think was about 11 hours if I'm
remembering it correctly this one like I
said is almost twice as long yes I think
it's gonna be like 20 hours maybe
something like that but we'll see I'm
hopefully I'm gonna start recording it
next week sometimes yeah tell about the
recordings yeah and this is something
else that we're gonna do you know in
regards to all of my books that are up
yeah now all of my horror fiction
because I you know mainly the last few
years I've been working on nonfiction
but I've also written a lot of horror
fiction as well I have not done
audiobook versions of those just because
I haven't had time to do them because
they're kind of long yeah and some of
them really were never published or not
compiled completely regularly
correctly because some other companies
had rights to them and they're getting
freed up soon so she's gonna retain
possession of some old writings and she
had basically what we're going to do is
are gonna make at least two possibly
three big compilations of stories of
those different sizes as far as the
medium-sized stories kind of like the
kind of like the books that you grew up
with a kid you know with Stephen King
compilations you know it could be
something like that and it'll be they
will be available in print some of them
for the first time in a big book but
probably 400 pages each one of those
well that's what I'm shooting for like
I'm going to do because I have two
collections of short stories already
which is hopeful monsters and the
associated villanies yeah what I'm
probably gonna do with those I'm gonna
leave those stories where they are but
I'll probably put out a new edition with
a new cover and stuff like that and then
I'm going to record audio versions of
the ride because they've never been
available in audios yeah and then I have
some shorter novels novellas some short
stories whose rights I just got back
that were in other compilations a long
time ago some short stories that I never
published
so I actually probably have another
three or four books worth of material
yeah and so I'm kind of thinking about
putting them all out as kind of a a
matched set type of thing like the Jenny
Ashford collection yes so basically
there's gonna be four more books and
audio books of decent size at least for
me at least four more gonna come out
rapidly all right and they're gonna come
out in print and in audio you guys are
gonna love them yeah so it's gonna be a
while because it's gonna take me a while
to put them all together yeah a lot of
stuff it's already written it's just it
all has to be recorded formatted
re-edited yeah that's that's a project
that I'm going to be undertaking in the
next couple months probably you know at
the same time as I'm working on faceless
villain vol 3 which is hoping like I was
gonna try and have that out by the end
of this year but it might be early next
year like spring of action then talk
about the recordings on the older books
yeah and like I said I'm gonna I know
every record yeah oh yeah yeah I'm gonna
my tree record some of the nonfiction do
you have a new microphone sound quality
on some of the
you know some of the older non-fiction
books wasn't that good I I think the
reading on unseen hand I think some
people complained it was a little dry
yeah people that we're used to listening
to me on here right so she's probably
gonna read we're gonna redo that the
audio quality better than the readings
gonna be like a little more naturalistic
what you guys are used to here and you
know you know what she sounds like
normally during the podcast yes people
people are used to that now yeah so
it'll have more of a friendly read to it
I think yeah we were actually trying to
do it kind of clinically in a way
well because it's sort of like it it's
not really a textbook textbook but it
was kind of like a more dry topic I
suppose yeah and some people didn't like
it I think they'd like it better just a
normal reading voice yeah and I'll try
to do it more you know I'm not gonna
like you know it should take all that
long to get everything re-released and
recompiled it you know months but you'll
see you guys are gonna start seeing some
new stuff some new stuff coming out and
we're gonna hand out a lot of free
samples to our favorite and like I said
faceless fill and volume tool should be
out very soon because I mean I have to
record it but the print and the eBook
version should be up yeah once it's
we're a couple weeks maybe once it's
ready if you have an Amazon account you
can hit us up and we'll send you a free
audiobook version in exchange for a
review yeah which kind of sucks is we
handed out a lot of them in the past and
never got reviews back it turns out the
shame on you turns out you had to have
an Amazon account I think in order to be
able to actually yeah leave the review
and I think some of the people that
actually asked for a new ass forum
didn't have an Amazon account yeah I'm
not sure that works because it's like
I've always had an Amazon action you had
people yeah deal contactors hey I'm
trying to leave trying to leave a real
positive review but it won't let me
because I don't have an Amazon account
yeah okay well yeah I'll see if I can
sort that out and there's some kind of
those reviews help us where's the book
yeah yeah for real I mean they really do
make a difference the book does many
reviews on it it doesn't sell yeah
exactly
so let's see what else um as always if
you'd like to financially support the
show you can go to our patreon page at
patreon.com slash 18 o'clock podcast or
you can go to our blog which is 13
o'clock podcast wordpress.com there's a
link in this sidebar to a pal account
yes we have two new patrons that we want
to say hello - hello - Jason yeah and
hello - creepy creeps
yeah which I love that that's awesome
and also big shout out to our good buddy
Eric who you'll often see in the YouTube
comments
mmm he gave us a very generous donation
again over PayPal yeah he says it's like
50 a lot of times that's awesome yeah
we're getting there we're getting there
and like I said when we get to a
thousand dollars on patreon two thousand
dollars a month on patreon we are going
to launch a third weekly show yeah I
will probably be putting it up on
Sundays called Time Machine thirteen
gonna be like a retro show just stuff
shooting the [ __ ] about yes def we
remember from our childhood it's movies
toys at least that's the technology at
least that's the plan I mean once we get
it getting a couple of minute can we
look at them we don't think it'll work
maybe we'll change it to something else
but I think that might work yeah I like
that idea and we have like we already
have like a big huge you know list of
topics you want to cover on it so I
think I think it'll be good we can get
quite a bit of mileage out of that I
think you know and I think people will
be entertained even though everyone's
not as old as us yeah but it might be
funny and it like you know back in my
day kind of way like young people are
like whoa people didn't used to have
phones in their pockets and people used
to only have three channels oh really
yeah well the dark ages we don't know we
don't really know exactly what it's
gonna be yet we have to do we have to
try to get it get them executed and get
them done yeah we're so like brain
stores don't brainstorming how it's
gonna
it's gonna go yeah that's definitely
something that we're looking into doing
down the line also if you haven't seen
it yet check out our latest movie review
which was a Clockwork Orange
yeah very favorite movies of all time
and we did a very fun review of that
also check out if you go to the game
crafter comment it's the game crafter
calm and search for giallo games I then
I have one game called a crimson drop on
a crystal palette I showed it a couple
episodes ago because I have a copy of it
I have that game up and I have a
expansion pack up for it
I also two more games that are like
ready to go I just need to order them
and proof them and all that other stuff
but they're already up there so it'll be
like you know in a couple weeks or
months those should be available also
and I'll probably like working on
another one you've got a mention on beer
and board games we did I was so excited
I sent him a card like a long time ago
cuz you know Craig on there Craig
Johnson he collects postcards so I had a
bunch of cool postcards like from New
Mexico and from various places in
Florida that I had been over the years
so I sent him like a little envelope
full of stuff and I wrote them a card
about how how I was a big fan of theirs
and wishing him a happy birthday from
July so before July that I sent it and
on there Pat on their show which was
their most recent one which was an
unboxing
welcome to the basement they actually
they said we've we missed this one was
like we got it a long time ago I got
lost on the desk yeah and so they read
part of my card and I was like a shout
out to 13 o'clock
yeah and they showed our post card and
everything I was so so excited you got I
just like totally geeked out it was
we're gonna send him a copy that game
yeah see that's what well yeah they kind
of wash and beer and board games has
kind of got me was you know got me
interested back in doing designing games
right so that was kind of one of the one
of my plans as I was gonna send them a
copy of it and maybe buy that some beer
so they would play it was there anything
else I think that's it oh and also you
know we have we still have our channels
on bit shoot and vo that's right
very slowly dailymotion yeah [ __ ] shoes
descriptions are going up a little bit I
think we're at like 1516 subscriptions
guys need to go check us out make a bit
sheet accounts really fast and easy to
make one make a [ __ ] sheet account in
case we ever get banned here blocked or
anything bad happens you'll still be
able to find us although you can also
find us through Facebook through
facebook too but well I'm the thing too
is that I would probably do it I mean if
anything like I said I don't first see
anything bad happening but if it did I
would just do what I've been doing with
the audio podcasts all along and just
upload everything to archive.org because
you can put as much [ __ ] as you want now
all of our audio episodes are on there
that's you know where people get it from
you Tunes iTunes or whatever so just
another one everybody says good thing
called d2d tube and then there's another
one I forgot what it was I can check it
again but they're new new platforms are
emerging and they're getting they're
getting better they're getting a lot
better yeah so like I said hey we gotta
you know plant seeds in other fields too
you know maybe some people you know have
thirty five thousand subscribers in did
she you know a bit shoot alone you know
it all kind of adds up yeah so we're
just balls are eyeballs I don't care
where you are that's true yeah and so I
think that's all the shoutouts probably
now we're really gonna do only one news
story today yeah this is the news thank
you I keep telling you this week
Caroline okay and like I said I like to
do you know kind of a story that relates
to one of our main topics so I want to
do a true crime story and you guys know
how much I love when she just as in the
case of the Golden State killer when DNA
is used to catch a [ __ ] say
caught it from some cold case from a
long time ago that probably the victims
family thought was never going to be
solved
until the magic of DNA yeah found the
person person I used that term loosely
responsible yeah so there was a cold
case this happened in Lancaster
Pennsylvania and it happened a couple
days before Christmas it was December
21st 1992 and there was this sixth grade
school teacher at an elementary school
her name was Chris team Iraq and she
didn't turn up to teach her classes one
day and the principal of the elementary
school thought that was very odd so he
went to her house to check on her finds
the door open of her house goes in there
and finds her lying face down dead in
her [ __ ] house clad in her winter
coat naked from the waist down she has
been raped and beaten to death huh now
for many years they couldn't figure out
who she was she was 25 years old 25
years old she's a sixth grade teacher
right somebody just came in her house
and raped her and just beat her to death
and just left her there yeah and this
happened in 1992 and for years and years
they they had no idea who this could
have been it's like she had no enemies
nothing like that so then you know the
the cold-case investigators really
wanted to solve this because they're
like you know this poor woman it's like
she was young she do anything it's like
they just had no idea and they were like
and so they really put a lot of effort
into solving this and they ended up
going through this particular like
genetic
testing company and they had because
they had a DNA sample they had a semen
sample from the scene and they ended up
doing exactly what the investigators did
in the original Nightstalker gold and
say killer case learn this including the
DNA to GED match and seeing if they
could triangulate this person based on
if any of their family members had
uploaded their DNA profile willingly and
like I said I know a lot of people
freaked out about it and rights and
everything like that but GED match the
reason they use that one is because that
is a voluntary service you don't have to
upload your DNA you know it's a
genealogy website so people upload their
DNA profiles willingly and they're
trying to so they're trying to find a
match to like a close family member well
they ended up finding one and they
actually I don't know it didn't really
say in the article like who's what
relative or how close a relative this
was but they eventually narrowed the
suspect down to this guy named Raymond
Rowe otherwise known as DJ fries are
easy which already yeah and evidently he
was a fairly well known party DJ okay in
the Lancaster Pennsylvania area his
website and I love this said he started
out in the 80s as a breakdancer okay so
even more douche points right there so
they found out that at the time that
Christy maroc was murdered he only lived
about four miles away from her so you
know obviously they're like okay well we
think that's just this is who it is but
they did just like they did in Golden
State killer they said okay we're gonna
stake him out so he had a gig at an
elementary school cuz I mean he's 49
years old so it's that you know he sees
like over yeah yeah he doesn't look like
it they're from the picture he looks
younger I thought he looked younger but
um but yeah so like I said he's started
I was a breakdancer so that should tell
you all you need to know so he was
playing a DJ gig at an elementary school
and undercover in bed
two Gators watched him and then they saw
him throw away a water bottle and spit
out some gum yes they got that and they
went and got it and that [ __ ] was a
match Wow and it was it's the they said
the odds of it being anyone else are
like one in 200 octillion or something
like that did he confess and see what
happened I don't think he did and it's
like the weird thing is that they said
that this dude was like not even on the
police radar yeah they're not even sure
if they knew each other right you just
saw yeah so it's like at this point I
mean he was arrested in late June so at
this point they're still investigating
like why he did it if they even knew
each other cuz like I said they don't
know if they if they did or if he just
randomly I made a SAR somewhere if he
was stalking her nobody knows so it's
just it's scary to me that like this
dude wasn't even a suspect I mean they
did have some suspects at the time but
he wasn't one of them so it's like they
didn't even chances are he did know her
or at least he saw her maybe it went to
his game that's what I mean I was kind
of thinking because particularly because
you know he did gigs at schools I mean
this was a long time ago it was 1992 but
um you know maybe he did a gig somewhere
at the school that she taught at and he
saw and got obsessed or who knows yeah
and found out that she lived near him
and then he went over there to look at
her and saw or maybe tried to meet her
and it didn't go well he killed her and
rape her yeah that's kind of what I'm
thinking okay but you know this is kind
and it seems like once the whole once
that thing happened with the Golden
State killer it really seems like
they've been solving a lot of cases that
way and you know that's kind of a happy
occurrence I wonder if that was if she
was the only law I'm kind of wondering
that too because usually [ __ ] like that
usually doesn't happen in yeah that's
not usually something that's just a
one-off type of thing I mean unless
they've been dating and as far as I know
they weren't right you know nobody said
anything about that like oh that was her
ex-boyfriend then she that would have
been the first well they investigated
they said this guy was just some Rando
we didn't know so yeah so so I'm gonna
kind of keep an eye on this and see what
happens with because now yeah now I'm
kind of curious but um you know her
family they interviewed her
CNN and stuff and you know obviously
he's very very happy that they finally
caught this guy and they sound like
finally said well you know allegedly but
you know the DNA matches so I'm sure
that that's probably it is and you know
like I said it's it's kind of a good
thing that the DNA service is being used
for that and as long as people are
voluntarily uploading their their thing
for genealogy purposes I don't really
see any problem with it you know it's
not like they're taking it from people
it's like you know I think I'd
eventually get down to that though it
may may be taking it from people at
Birth eventually it may I mean as it
some states have it where they can't
where they will take it from you if
you're convicted of a felony what
they're gonna do is is that when kids
are born they're gonna take a little
blood sample under some auspices like
we're to find him or someone do we have
to know his DNA Matt then later on the
ends up going it took like an NCIC
computer yeah they'll get around to it
yeah like I said at this point it's
still a voluntary yeah service and
they're using it for good they're gonna
make it so the parents do it voluntarily
to their children as they're born yeah
or a different auspice but then that's
kind of kept in the system so you can
find I mean you're on kids grow up when
those kids grow up if they commit crimes
they can track them down yeah and then
once they get you know they get they get
you used to it first and then it gets to
the point where you have to give it to
give up DNA part of your ID something
like that it very well may yeah I guess
we're gonna see how much they're gonna
met they're gonna meet your your genetic
code to your social security number well
that'll become one in the same thing
that you're you're some part of your DNA
will be your social security number and
be like your ID that's how the
government will identify you that's
eventually what it'll get to it's gonna
go like like Gattaca yeah that's a good
movie because I'm good yeah so I guess
that will be the end of the news segment
and then after
a little break or after a little
whatever we're doing here because I do
these in two pieces because you know I
need a break in between and then we're
going to talk about the case of the
Australian rapist and killer mr. cruel
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
and I think that's why there is so
significant because we are willing to
pay per day Jenny's got some new shirt
designs up four of them really good ones
to Atlanta Ripper who put Bella in the
which out the HH Holmes murder castle
and of course demon child cuz man said
he could these are updated designs I
think they look really cool Jenny did a
great job autumn where they found making
Jenny
they were very fun and thank you very
much I think they came out right yeah
yeah really good they're very
high-quality shirts Jenny and I we're
sure our own shirts at certain times
when we're trying to put spotlight on
ourselves and you can put a spotlight on
yourselves if you go ahead and pick up
on these shirts today you guys are gonna
love them
links in the description WWL comm at 13
o'clock yeah so go check out our store
at wwl com / 13 o'clock we got these
four cool new t-shirt designs plus all
our old ones if you'd rather get one of
the old ones but these ones are awesome
and you should check them out they're
also available in women's cut and they
look really cute Judy's got some so
thank you go check them out
okay now we're going to be talking about
the oft requested topic of mr. cruel
okay a kidnapper and killer from
Australia all right whose crimes
occurred in the late 80s in early 90s in
Australia all right now this man has
never been apprehended in many ways he's
very similar to like similar MO to
Golden State killer or slash original
Night Stalker type of thing where it was
like a total dominant situation he would
come in the house tie people up whatnot
and do what he was gonna do like a
takeover assailant yes then takes over
the scene yeah and like I said there are
a lot of I don't think that this
psychology and I kind of want to get
into this later but I don't think the
psychology of mr. cruel and original
Night Stalker were the same but in many
ways their methods were very very
similar and they had a really a lot of
similarities very direct approach yeah
between the way they did things so let's
go back to August of 1987 and there's
this town called lower Plenty and it is
a suburb of Melbourne Australia now this
first family that were affected by mr.
cruel have never been named in the media
as far as I know every breakdown of this
case that I've ever seen the first
family they they don't say any of their
names I'm not really sure why that is
perhaps they did not want their names
released to the public because you know
their daughter was one of the ones
victimized and she was minor the other
families are named but not the first one
so I'm not real sure why that is but and
if anybody knows their names let me know
but I I couldn't find them anywhere but
so here's this house it's August 22nd
it's 4:00 in the morning and a masked
intruder pulls a windowpane out of one
of the houses windows climbs in without
waking anyone he goes into the parents
bedroom he has a knife and a gun now he
says to them
to the parents he's like you know I'm
gonna kill you if you're gonna if you
don't do what I say blah blah blah now
he says all he wants his money right so
he said I'm just gonna go through your
[ __ ] and I'm gonna take all your money
now he tells the mom and dad to roll
over on their stomachs he ties them up
it puts tape over their mouths gags them
and stuff like that and then he puts
them in their wardrobe in the bedroom
good now
then he goes into the bedroom of their
son who was six now this kid he ties him
to the bed also gagged him put a
blindfold over him now at this stage it
becomes clear what this guy has come in
for he does not want money he wants the
11-year old daughter
okay so he that could only mean one
thing he knew where he was going yes and
they do think that mr. cruel in in much
the way that the Golden State killer did
was a very tactical person he you know
they think he may have stalked his the
families a long time beforehand and
things of that nature so that's another
similarity with that kind of thing so he
he obviously knew where he was going he
knew where all the bedrooms were he knew
the ages of the children and stuff so he
was prepared for this kind of [ __ ] now
this first attack like I said the girl
was 11 now the six-year-old son is tied
to the bed the parents are tied up
gagged blindfolded and in their wardrobe
mr. cruel is in their house for two
hours raping this little girl in the
house within the house okay and they're
all in there I don't know I'm presumably
they could hear her which that was a
horrible he's got some serious balls to
stay in that house for two hours that
he's not in a good way he knew that no
one would come yeah I'm you know
obviously you know he he rapes this
little 11 year old girl he takes a break
he goes in the kitchen and makes
food yeah comes back [ __ ] like that
thank you original nice dog yeah it's
like [ __ ] like the original nicer like
I'm gonna hang out in your house and
like do horrible [ __ ] you know add an
insult to injury yeah I'm gonna make a
burger your groceries I mean that is
[ __ ] up I mean you know everything he
does is [ __ ] up but for some reason
that's like another level of like [ __ ]
up right his dominance yeah yeah so he's
there for like two [ __ ] hours you
know makes food in this house finally
after two hours he leaves now he does
steal [ __ ] from their house but it
wasn't like money it was like random
[ __ ] he took a collection of classic
records
okay and he took a blue coat that's
ridiculous that's a classic records yeah
and then he took off he knew he knew
what a classic record was wonder if what
if he was gonna sell them or listen to
them he must have must've with that was
one way you could track him down
the records are long gone now but yeah
still you know you'd still hasn't which
I doubt it probably destroyed him
yeah resold them but it's like I said
now this first attack you know as I said
this was the first one that they know of
there may have been some prior to this
that they haven't revealed that may have
been connected but this is the first one
the first canonical mr. cruel crime and
as I said the family has never been
named none of their names have been
released as far as I know so that was
that and that and that was the first
that was really the only one where the
little girl was left in the house yeah
you know so which I just imagine can you
imagine I can't imagine that I can
imagine
well like it but I guys what I mean it's
like I don't really want to imagine it's
out there that's yeah that's horrible
one of the interesting things that came
to light when the police were
investigating this first case was that
the little 11 year old girl said that at
some point during one of the killers or
the you know the guys breaks she said
she heard him talking to someone she
thought that he was talking to some
on the phone like he had called someone
using the family's telephone and
evidently the guy said something that he
was like threatening someone he called
them bozo and he said something like you
better move your children or they'll be
next or bla bla bla so the little girl
said she heard him presumably talking to
someone else although when the cops
investigated they pulled the phone
records from the family's house no phone
call had been made he was talking to
himself yes so this is another thing now
I don't know if he was just like talking
to himself like in crazy person sort of
way or if it was something intended to
throw off the investigators because he
did do that on some of the later crimes
so he may have been thinking ahead like
he's like oh they'll think that I made a
phone call from the house and then
they'll find out that I didn't make one
or you know what I mean I don't see how
that would he seemed like I know but he
seemed like he was doing like weird
little things at every at every crime
scene yeah I think he's dude like me
actually where you know I get you get
mad and you go down into another semi
dimension you start talking you know how
like when I'm like in the bathroom yeah
talking you can you guys know that very
famous scene in The Shining where Jack
is walking down the hall by the gold
ballroom lady and he's like yeah that's
like Tom is exactly like it's calm and
you know a guy who has imagination you
know that he's thinking about it I mean
I talked to myself too but it's it's a
sign of a man with strong willpower and
he doesn't sleep - yeah yeah well I see
something in my head yeah and it might
be something hypothetical or it might be
something from the past or you know what
I mean and I'll interact with it a
little bit it's almost kind of like
Tourette's - it's a way that's kind of
what I'm saying this is very interesting
they did that
he's like oh man yelled at cloud yeah
yeah but yeah that's uh so yeah there
but like I said there were some similar
things in the later cases okay so at
this point like more than a year goes by
with no similar things occurring now the
next one happened on December twenty
seventh nineteen eighty eight now this
was the Wills
family the the mom and dad they had four
daughters and this actually it was only
a few miles away from where the first
one had taken place I think the the
suburb this suburb was called Ringwood
and same kind of thing it was it was
about 5:00 5:45 in the morning and all
of a sudden the dad wakes up and he's
got a gun pointed at his head and the
guy says to him don't be a hero right so
you know obviously the guy's like
freaking out so same kind of thing that
mom and dad are ordered to roll over on
their stomachs the the the guy they said
that he was wearing like a blue jumpsuit
and a blue like a ski mask or balaclava
type of thing so like I said very much
like the original lights dark where he
always were like a ski mask type thing
over his face okay so the mom and dad
were all over their stomachs he ties
their wrists and ankles with copper wire
and interestingly just like in the first
case and this is also very similar to
gold in the state killer the knots that
he used were nautical knots yeah people
that had been in the Navy or you know
they'd been on ships and stuff like that
so it was a very distinctive it could be
army though type of knot yeah it could
be saying that yeah so yeah it was it
was a sailor maybe navies are more not
centric especially in the old-school
navies yeah yeah so the same kind of
thing they're blindfolded they're gagged
now he actually kind of went through
their [ __ ] at their bedside table he
sold about $35 in cash then he went
around the house cutting all their phone
lines you know which had landlines back
then so he physically cut all the phone
lines and then he goes into the girls
bedroom and now all for the gray as far
as I can determine all four
the girls slept in the same room they
were all pretty little the oldest one
was Sharon and she was 10 and she was
the one that mr. cruel was after now the
weird thing was that he addressed her by
name he said wake up Sharon yeah he
knows so he knows who this he's done a
lot of planning obviously so he gets her
he gathers some of her clothes and takes
her out of the house 15 minutes later
the mom and dad you know get out of
their restraints and run into the into
the bedroom and find that little Sharon
is gone
so obviously the you know they don't
have a phone because all the phone lines
make cuts they have to run to the
neighbor's house and call the police and
then they start you know screaming and
running all over the neighborhood like
looking for this little girl so this guy
has the ability to do a background check
on a family some way or another either
that or he knows them ahead of time
which I kind of feel like is maybe the
case and I'm gonna somehow or another he
comes in contact with him and knows it's
an entire family like you know you may
not see the girl first maybe he sees the
father first or the mother first and he
finds out that they have a family and
then he's able to find out all the names
of all these kids yeah
which that takes some doing yeah there's
something going on here yeah some kind
of authority figure yes that is what I'm
or somebody in the educational system
what I'm leaning it's something like
that I think that's I think that's what
probably the case is with the balls
we're talking about breaking and
entering the nots the guns the knives
the familiarity with police systems I'm
gonna go right along right along down
that same line as as Golden State killer
cop cop yeah ex-military cop
it wouldn't surprise me he may not be an
active duty cop maybe he's an ex-cop a
fire cop well DeAngelo wasn't either
yeah he had been a cop at some yeah and
he had
D'Angelo was more burglar than copy you
not I mean it was both yeah and you know
a lot of that a lot of those kind of
guys there are badasses they can walk on
both sides of the fence for a certain
amount of time they can pretend to be a
good guy but they're just bad guys yeah
you know boss you know they got balls
but here's the weird thing you know the
guys bending over backwards and
expending all this energy and using his
skillset to go after little girls yeah
you know which know this guy like I said
that problem since I feel like other
than um God he's got self-esteem
problems yeah other than the many
similarities with the way that this guy
approached his crimes as you know Golden
State killer did like I said I don't
think the psychology is the same I
carried you to you one thing though this
is another little dick [ __ ]
aren't they all this is a little dick
Mellon I feel like most of them probably
are because why you know what otherwise
why would you even yeah conceivably you
know usually when you have a guy who's
just fixated on pedophilia it's because
he can't impress a full-grown woman yeah
the only impress and terrorize a little
girl yeah you know it's again it's a
power issue but I feel like I feel like
Golden State killer was just more of a
general rage monster he just everybody
that knew him said you know he was a
giant tool it's like he was just always
yeah mad he was always angry this guy
comes across as a little bit different
go man if you're a little dick
[ __ ] you can overcome you can
compensate in positive ways you don't
have to be you know what I mean it's
only assert it's like it's only a
certain kind of guy who reacts that
certain way yeah I mean it's you know
it's like it's a really really small
yeah it's a very very small part I
didn't mean it like that I'm just saying
it's you know but I mean it's like if if
you do have a small dick out there it's
like you know there are whole nations
there are whole nations a little dick
you know it's like breathe funny be nice
be just like be smart be something and
just be who you are yeah just like you
can have other things to offer there are
other things to offer seriously it's
like everyone doesn't everyone's not
good at everything and it doesn't have
all it took me a very long time to learn
that okay but yes I'm just saying that
you know please don't become a pedophile
or a serial killer it's like that's just
really that's like the nuclear option
it's like please never ever take that
it's always somebody who's really got
some issues well obviously so here's
this poor little ten-year-old girl
Sharon Sharon wills has been taken from
her house 18 hours later it's about
midnight and this woman is walking
around she sees a little girl standing
on a street corner wearing garbage bags
huh and they said now Fairplay to this
little girl she's 10 yeah
and the woman said she was very calm and
she said to the woman she's like my name
is Sharon Wells and I got taken from my
house and a man left me here and told me
to go call home all right you know she
was very calm in garbage bags he did her
clothes yeah yeah he didn't want it
didn't want any transference of any data
of like hair and semen samples and
things like that he knew about that yep
so yeah when when they got her back home
to her you know obviously relieved
parents I mean you know she had been
through a horrible ordeal obviously she
said she had been blindfolded the whole
time she couldn't see the guy she said
that he had actually been fairly mean
other than the rape he had actually been
kind of nice to her she said he was very
soft-spoken
she said he was gentle she had given him
he had given her a Vegemite sandwich to
eat which that sounds a little yeah well
it it's not it's a thing where I guess
if you grew up in Austria
probably it's kind of like other British
don't like peanut butter yeah smack a
British bread over peanut butter
yeah with jelly and we you guys call
that jam because you know well jelly
jelly is jello yeah for us
jelly jelly is jam without fruit
particles in it yeah yeah that's usually
called an fu marmalade or and if you put
good peanut butter on some toasted bread
okay with butter on it too and some
great jelly or you call it grape jam man
it's you know come on you can't beat it
is very delicious especially after like
you know salt in the sweet mixed
together and the toasted mists of the
bread and the butter oh I didn't get my
fav although it's good with butter on it
- yeah especially like if you're drunk
and you don't feel like cooking anything
happy toes go in there toast some bread
like toasted white bread or wheat bread
- worst wheat breads good - yeah yes so
she had eaten a Vegemite sandwich eat
eat and some lemon drunk some lemonade
and some milk and what the guy had done
and apparently she's had the blind she
was had the blindfold on the whole time
she was gone for 18 hours he bathed her
he brushed her teeth he flossed her
teeth he cut her fingernails and
toenails so he was trying to get rid of
all right he's trying to get rid of any
they never found her clothes and he had
taken like other than what she had the
little jammy she was sleeping in he took
some of her clothes - like from her room
they never found those so he obviously
yeah he there kept them or he threw them
away or burn them or whatever and he so
he washed her and dressed her garbage
bags and left her on the side of the
road at [ __ ] midnight well bad stuff
had already happened to her so yeah I'm
safe right that's what he was thinking
about now she also um was able to tell
police even though she didn't get a look
at him she said that she thought she
heard low-flying planes meaning that the
guy probably lived near flight path
of an airport and she thought she heard
something that sounded like a camera
starting her camera running
so yeah so there's they think there's a
child porn angle here - that's for him
though he's not selling it out um yeah I
don't know it's I don't know how you
remember it yeah so yeah too much too
risky to sell that yeah well I don't
think they sell it I think they treat it
too risky to trade it that if the guy he
trades it with gets popped then all of a
sudden the photographs fall into the
custody of the law enforcement he's
tracked down so no it's for himself now
at this stage they have linked the
attack on the Wills family are on Sharon
wills with the previous attack that
happened in lower plenty of the unnamed
family and they're calling the
perpetrator of the Hampton rapist and
it's kind of sad because you know months
go by like the Wills family the dad John
wills was actually very traumatized by
the whole because he you know he
couldn't protect his daughter he he'd
failed to protect his family and he was
very upset about it the family like
would all had they slept in the same
room they got guard dogs I got alarms
they got all kind of stuff because the
guy just busted and in the [ __ ]
middle of the night so you know they
didn't really have much to go on they
didn't have any suspects nothing like
that so well then there was the next
crime didn't occur until July of 1990
and this happened and all of these
happen I mean Melbourne was a fairly
safe city I mean they had crime
obviously but the crime rate was very
low for a city of that size and a lot of
these crimes I'm not sure about the
first family but the second family and
or the the subsequent three families
that were victimized were actually their
upper middle-class families and there
were very nice neighborhoods so this
wasn't a kind of thing so he was he's
the same class so yeah I'm kind of
feeling like he probably was and
like I said I feel like he kind of ran
in the same circles like he knew who
these people were so this next family
were the Linus family and they were
actually British they had lived in
Melbourne because of the dad's job like
he had been transferred there for a
little while and they lived in this kind
of you know upper middle-class suburb
called Canterbury Victoria just outside
of Melbourne and they were actually
whatever his work thing that was doing
in Australia was actually coming to an
end so they were going to move back to
England probably you know like a week or
two later now on July 3rd the parents
had actually been invited to like a
going-away party because they were
moving back now they had two teenage
daughters and the teenage daughters were
left home alone so and the parents went
off to the party and they weren't gone
that long you know they were only gone
for a few hours now
the two daughters were fifteen-year-old
Fiona and 13 year old Nicola so they had
been at home hanging out watching movies
or whatever they went to bed a little
bit before midnight after they had gone
to sleep someone busted into their house
and again had a knife and a gun he had
his ski mask on he was wearing like a
greenish tracksuit they said he takes he
tells Nicola the younger one he's like
go and get your school uniform yeah so
he tells you to go get her school
uniform and he wanted her in that yeah
Fiona the older sister she gets tied up
and he basically says to the older
sister tell your dad that I want $25,000
for Nicholas returned and then he takes
off with the 13 year old you didn't want
the 15 year old he wanted the 13 year
old yeah now the guy stole evidently
there was a rental car that belonged to
the family and he put the girl in the
rental car and took it and then they
drove a little way
and then he transferred her to another
car which I guess he had left waiting
the so well said he's planning all this
[ __ ] yeah so he's intelligent he's
disciplined yeah he's got balls I'm like
I said he's got an attorney this is an
ex-military czar and and the attacks are
a long time apart like a year year and a
half apart so he seems like he's
spending a lot of time like yeah
narrowing down the victim and planning
what he's military guy cop also probably
or cop type and he's fascinated with
young girls
yeah and he's gonna do what he can to
get him yeah and that's yeah that's he's
got a weird family
I got a weird feeling that this dude may
be married yeah maybe he's married and
got money more and he's got an extra
location where he can do this he's not
doing this at his house he's doing this
at another piece of property that he
owns it may very well be yeah but yeah
so and cookie says every now and then
it's good yeah he's doing it when he can
get away with it when his wife's not
watching and something that they noted
later on was that every single one had
taken place when schools were out for
the holidays like for various holidays
summer holiday Christmas holiday
whatever it was always during a school
holiday is she a teacher that's I was
leaning toward that or somebody it
worked in the school system yeah um you
know and like I said at least in the
Sharon wills case he knew her name yeah
so yeah I feel like there might be some
of that
so somebody works in connection with the
school yeah so the parents come home
could he be a cop that guards a school
like a cop security guard top see well
you know like the school security guard
yeah we got a school we got a school
right here near our house there's always
a cop car parked out I mean I don't was
that a thing cuz I graduated from high
school in 1990 I don't know it wasn't
really a thing in 1990 and at least
where I was and this is Australia so I
they have one of these security officers
you have one of these like a respectable
public high school so right after this
public schools right up here the street
and yeah it's got heavy police
protection
it always has had it well they started
doing that after compromise shootings
and all that kind of stuff like I said
when I was in school we didn't have any
something like that and she said she and
and she's not they're not reporting that
this guy's like super overweight or
anything like that he's actually in
physical fitness right the only thing
they ever said and this is something
that Nicola said when she was returned
because I was kind of getting to that
now because niccola's parents the Linus
family they come back from the party
about 20 minutes after the kidnapper
left and they find Fiona the 15 year old
she's tied up in her bed and she tells
them what the kidnapper said you know
$25,000
although the thing is he didn't really
do it for ransom clearly because he
didn't tell them he didn't contact them
there was no way to give them the money
area so even though the guy right even
though the guy and like I said he did
that kind of [ __ ] though right you know
so he's he's meticulous in playing the
crime to get it done but he's not so
meticulous to plan like you know cover
stories and how to act you know what I
mean and how to actually cover his
tracks what his true motive is yeah you
know he's just he's just saying what he
has to say at any given moment it comes
right on with the victims yeah there was
a lot of that kind of shot going on so
you know so at this stage now fifty
hours after the abduction they find
Nicola and she is sitting outside of
like an electric like a power station in
Kew now she has all her clothes she's
wrapped in a blanket and he he she says
that the kidnapper told her to just lay
there and not look at him until he
driven away and then because she had
been blindfolded the whole time - now
the thing about her though is that even
though she was blindfolded the whole
time she actually
managed to get a couple glimpses of
things she actually got a good enough
look at a couple of rooms in his house
that she could describe them and they're
actually someone has drawn like a little
layout of what the bedroom and what the
bathroom looked like she couldn't see
him she said but she she thought she saw
a little bit of his hair and then it
looked like it was reddish-brown like it
was sticking out from underneath his his
mask she said she also thought he was
only about five foot eight she said
because she was quite tall for a 13 year
old girl but she said he was only a
couple of inches taller than her um you
know she's like when he was stuffing her
into the car she was trying to note like
how tall he was she thought he was about
five foot eight so she said the same
thing that Sharron wills had said that
she also heard low-flying planes and
thought she heard something that sounded
like a camera hmm so that was something
that they they kind of figure at this
point okay well he obviously you know
they know what the bedroom looks like
they know what the bathroom looks like
it's you know what is like rough it
wasn't like a super complicated but the
bathroom if you see the sketch of the
bathroom it just looks like a regular
bathroom the bedroom was just had a you
know it out of bed it had a like
full-length curtains that were like
peach colored fully decorated it was a
regular it was just regular looking it
just looked like a regular house she
only saw two rooms like cleaning dirty
though I don't know she didn't say but
yeah so she had actually been restrained
with a neck brace it was like a neck
thing that was like attached to the bed
and she'd been so she was stuck in this
thing with this thing around her neck so
another thing that Nicola reported which
was the same as the first unnamed family
was that she had heard the perpetrator
talking to someone else although she
didn't hear anyone answering so she
didn't know if he was on the phone if he
was talking to himself he was talking to
someone else that did an answer or if he
was just trying to
you plant a sort of red herring type of
thing like oh I got an accomplice and
I'm talking to this other accomplice but
she did hear him seemingly talking to
someone else just like the first family
said she thought she heard him like
yelling on the phone to somebody so same
type of thing so I don't know if he was
doing that [ __ ] on purpose
or if he was just talking to himself or
what hung himself yes so they were able
to kind of narrow it down they said okay
well since two people now said that they
hear low-flying planes and since these
crimes were all in pretty close
proximity to one another they were
usually suburbs you know outside of
Melbourne only a few miles away from
each other they figured that this had to
be somebody that lived probably in the
direct flight path of tullamarine
Airport now they started investigating
and you know you'd think that now that
they knew how tall the guy was what
color his hair probably was [ __ ] like
that and where he probably lived you'd
think that they'd be able to find
somebody but they couldn't know yeah
variables there are yeah I mean that's
yeah it sounds like oh well done guys
yeah but there's like thousands and
thousands and thousands of people that
could be and then it wouldn't stick in
court you know you have to write exactly
and you know so what are you gonna do
now
sadly the next crime and what they think
was the last crime now they called him
mr. cruel I'm not really sure why
because I read particularly well I read
somewhere that initially someone in the
media called him mr. cool yeah because
he wasn't getting raging stuff but then
someone else like at another newspaper
or something heard it as cruel and
thought that was a better name so called
in that I don't know if that's true or
not but I have seen that every day that
he's soft-spoken he's not he's not mean
to these girls he's let other than the
rapes but he's not [ __ ] he's not beating
that guy he's not tired he's not nice
screaming at them he's not doing
anything like that like I said he's not
a rage monster like what you're dealing
with this you're dealing with the guy
who actually thinks he's Don Juan yeah
this is abduction where he's taking
these girls he's treating them nice in
his mind and he's letting
go he kind of sees himself as Don Juan
and these girls enjoy it
and at least one or two of the victims
actually did say that he referred to
them like a lot of times he refers them
by name so he knew who they were but he
would call them Missy yeah one of the
girls said that she thought that he was
pretending that they were married like
she was his wife
so actually you kind of called that he's
he he has this fantasy about these
little girls loving him yeah and he's
being nice to them I give you a sandwich
I gave you some lemonade
there was one case where it involved
adults you know guy comes in comes in
comes in through some girl's window he
puts them he rapes her puts the moves on
her afterwards and she had presence of
mind to say hey what's your phone number
yeah you say you mentioned that but he
gave ya his phone in his mind girl
what's your phone number they love him
yeah I mean so of course that they're
gonna want to call him back you know and
he that he thinks he's doing something
good for girls that kind of presumption
is yeah Casanova Don Juan you know Errol
Flynn Errol Flynn was actually kind of
like that actually yeah so this next
case which they think is the last one
and this one is very sad because as it
is you know serial offenders you know
they tend to escalate just as it did in
the original night stalkers start out
with burglaries and he went out to rapes
and then he went on to murders same kind
of thing happened in this case
now this occurred in April of 1991 so
like I said there's quite a long time in
between these crimes now this was um
there was a couple named John and
Phyllis Chan they were Chinese
immigrants they owned several
restaurants they were actually very
wealthy lived in
kind of a mansion a type of house in a
very upper middle-class neighborhood so
they had three daughters the oldest one
was Carmen and she would often babysit
the younger ones you know because their
parents were pretty much at work all the
time they had several restaurants and
they were always like managing them so
they were always away from home so April
13 1991 which was also a Saturday just
like the first one just like usual
Saturday the parents were working at the
restaurant so Carmen and the two younger
her two younger sisters were at home you
know watching TV doing whatever they
were gonna do now it was only about 20
minutes to 9:00 and Carmen and one of
the other sisters are going into the
kitchen to get something to eat and they
see a guy standing there in a ski mask
and he has a knife and a gun he and he
says to them just like he said the other
ones I'm only gonna steal stuff
everything's fine you know [ __ ] like
that so he takes the two younger sisters
stuffs them in a closet and pushes a bed
up against the closet so they can't get
out then he takes the oldest daughter
Carmen and he says she's gonna show me
where the money is except now he took
her right so he takes off with her the
two younger sisters bust out of the
closet call their dad the police came
now here's another thing he knew were
little girls
yeah and he knew where little girls were
unguarded yeah he knew that their
parents would be gone so like I said and
here's another thing when the police got
there they noticed that the mom Phyllis
Chan someone had spray-painted or
written on her car
pay back Asian drug dealer more to come
so right so that's why I'm thinking the
whole thing with the phone call at the
one and like the talking to the other
person to you thing are like meant to
throw people off because it's like why
would you use that
it is but why would he do that other one
he's trying to [ __ ] throw shade on the
Asian family yea the drug dealers that's
why yeah but it did work because the
investigators did they went down well
they had to I mean they figured this was
probably the same guy but they have to
investigate every single you know live
inquiry so they had to go through all of
the Chan's you know business dealings
and make sure that and they were totally
legit they were yes which slowed him
down which is kind of a shame so but
like I said mr. cruel knew that that's
what would happen he knew they have to
invest like you ever kind of think it
was ninety one yet this was 91 this was
still a long time ago it was a very long
time ago like I said so as I said you
know they know okay this is the guy this
is the mr. cruel guy now so they're
waiting for their daughter to be
returned because every other time the
daughter has been returned this time
that girl was not returned
she's an asian girl yeah so months go by
and I'm telling you something right now
like the outline for this and actually
the unresolved podcast Michael Whelan he
actually did a really good breakdown of
this case and I what his podcast is I
showed my favorite true crime podcast
because he goes way deep and he he
doesn't do a ton but I mean he's got a
lot and the nice thing is that he writes
out like a transcript of every show like
on his blog which is really it's useful
for me because I can use it kind of as a
rough outline like for all this stuff
because he's a really good writer and he
gets all the details Jenny's quality
control yeah it's it's a good it's a
good show now on his podcast and I'm not
gonna do this cuz I I cried listening to
it honestly they have audio of Carmen
Chan's mom like asking that the
kidnapper to bring Carmen back and since
I knew what happened to her I was like
yeah it really was it really bothered me
listening here Lam to it so at this
stage they do this is the largest
manhunts pretty much in Australian
history which is look
everywhere for this poor little girl her
parents even published I thought this
was kind of interesting they published a
cipher in the newspaper that they knew
that their daughter would be able to
solve like and I don't remember what it
said but it said some various thing and
their little sisters like published
things in the paper and [ __ ] like that
so months go by
they spent all this money they started a
whole thing called operation spectrum
millions of dollars they interviewed
hundreds of thousands of people but
unfortunately almost a year later April
9th 1992 a guy was out walking his dog
and found a skeleton hmm and it was
Carmen Chan she had been shot three
times in the head execution style did
they do do they know the caliber not
that I know of actually I'm not sure
that I purchased that the German he was
using during the abductions was a real
gun you at least had one so yeah yeah
now they're not entirely sure I mean
what they're kind of thinking it's like
yes this could be just an escalation as
I said in the case of the you know
original night stalker but I think the
more likely thing and actually her
parents and the investigators thought
this as well they said that Carmen must
have seen him Zambia and that she might
have known who he was yeah they had
killed and so at that point he had to
kill her so I mean that which you would
think that all these victims you could
you could trace back what they had in
common to find this guy they didn't but
they didn't do this so it tells me that
maybe there isn't a clear connection
between him there may not be now what
they were kind of you know I mean like I
they yeah often the same school you
would know two of them were two of them
or two of them went to the same school
Carmen and I believe Nicola went to the
same school the other ones were younger
so I think they went to different
schools but they were in that same area
yeah it was all if these are all like I
said suburb somebody's not gonna be
connected to all those schools yeah so
now one
in some way weird if there was a silver
lining to come out of all of this
operation spectrum which lasted several
years they were kind of operating under
the assumption that's you know since
some of the victims said about a camera
and things they said well maybe this
guy's like on the underground child porn
type thing so they went they well they
went deep in investigating that and they
did end up arresting 70 people right but
they're not sure if the people who there
was they couldn't tie any of those guys
but they did get 70 [ __ ] pedophiles
yeah but yeah maybe not so they did get
70 people that were involved in child
porn so you know even if he wasn't one
of them then you know that was something
at least was training those folks yeah
so operation Spector that was too
disciplined for that
yeah weird for his own personal use and
he was forced to kill that girl because
that mission got caught yeah like I set
out and even even his which tells me
this is a true pedophile he and his mind
loved those girls yeah I get that
impression yeah and then he had to kill
that one and I think he retired yeah
because I think he was probably in his
30s or 40s which would mean that he's
he's either an old he's either an old
man or he's dead by now well now one of
the things okay so the the murder of
Carmen Chan was the last one that was
attributed to mr. cruel and they don't
think there were some that were about a
dozen that took place before the first
one like in the mid to late 80s that
were that had some similarities that
they said could have been early crimes
the same guy but they're not entirely
sure but there could be a connection as
far as I know there are no later ones
that they think were him so they're
thinking he either stopped or he died he
could have killed himself now one of the
things I find was very interesting like
I said investigators were kind of
exploring the possibility that he was
involved in the school system somehow
that he had been a cop that he had
because he was very like all his victims
he would bathe them and clip their
fingernails and toenails and floss their
teeth and all this other kind of stuff
so he obviously knew and this was in the
late 80s early 90s when you know we
didn't have a million true crime shows
where everybody knows about DNA and [ __ ]
like that so he was obviously very um he
knew about that yeah he was tuned into
that kind of [ __ ] so he knew that that
he had to do that so they think maybe
Cop maybe military maybe all three you
know it's it could be I think he was
right so now they also now so in 2010
they decided they were going to start a
new task force to try and find out who
this guy was and it was called task
force Apollo now in it's funny because
well not funny but you know I mean mr.
cruel has almost become kind of like a
boogeyman like an urban legend type
thing even though [ __ ] really did happen
but you know he's this masked man that
comes the bus in your house the middle
of night takes your daughters and this
kind of thing so it's almost like this
weird like urban legend has sprung up
around him so one of the people that
they were looking at who seems to me a
rather likely suspect was and they found
this guy in 2013 his name was Robert
Keith Knight now he had been he had
volunteered at several schools he was
like a counselor like a youth worker
counselor volunteer type of person now
he was arrested in 1980 and again in
1996 for sexual assaults on minors and
after he was arrested a bunch of other
girls came out and was like yeah that
guy molested me as well so this so this
guy was someone that they were seriously
looking at I'm gonna say no now he got
out of prison in 1996 then in 2009 they
arrested him again and they found that
he had like all of these always child
porn
all these images and stuff like that so
they arrested him again now while he was
awaiting trial he jumped out of a window
and committed suicide
yeah so I'm gonna say that's not him
though could have been him
maybe not but we'll never know why he
does whoever did these abductions was
careful and very disciplined and that
was his MO he only had that mo this
other guy was sloppy yeah and got caught
in that you know he's using child porn
and his pictures you know the pictures
that he took of that girl would have
been mixed in with that it wasn't him it
was just another pedophile I think the
guy that and I guess there are a lot of
those guys yeah
mr. cruel was that guy who did just
those abductions I don't think he didn't
have like I said it seems very much like
Golden State killer where it's like he
did all of this I mean Golden State
killer obviously he did way more but
then he just started and he didn't do
anymore
he was whoever this guy is he was doing
these abductions like commando missions
and that was all he did that was that
was how he was gonna conduct this yeah
there wasn't any of this like random
child molestation you know with without
masks and all that no you wouldn't like
that yeah this guy's very very careful
very disciplined well clearly probably
was more into quality than quantity what
I mean by quality each crime that he
committed was one that he could that he
could get away with yeah there's no
evidence is really that well yeah and he
was very very careful about that like
they found very very little physical the
kind of guy who's gonna be really
careful one day and then sloppy the next
you know that yeah I mean they found
hardly anything I think the most they
ever found was maybe a couple footprints
that you know they the dog tracked it to
like where the car wasn't and they lost
the scent it's like you know no DNA no
hair no blood no nothing I think he
actually kind of was like emotionally
really into these girls and you
he thought he was Don Juan and he had
affection for almond shet and this is a
big exciting fantasy and we was forced
to kill one of them I think he stopped
that may have been the case I mean there
there was actually a crime in 2011 where
a little 13 year old girl was abducted
and that was unsolved and some people
have speculated that maybe that was the
same guy that he was coming out of
retirement or whatever but I do think it
might be I mean it might be because he
did he did these horrible things these
girls like he would keep them and but
then he would let them go and he didn't
really seem to I mean like I said he
didn't beat them up he wasn't you know
violent in the sense I mean obviously
rape is violent but he wasn't like you
know beating them or doing anything
unnecessary in that line and then he
would let them go now the last girl if
he did have to kill her because she saw
him or whatever because he did say he
did say to one or two of the other
victims that lived he said my freedom is
more important than your life yeah yeah
so I'm assuming he had the carbon chain
saw his face yeah and then when it came
down to actually kill him one of these
girls it [ __ ] him up yeah and maybe
yeah and maybe he didn't want to do it
anymore because maybe I think that I
thought it was too much of a risk
he realized maybe the fantasy wasn't
worth it yeah something like that I mean
hopefully hopefully actually hopefully
he's [ __ ] dead but you know because he
sounds like he didn't see this as rape
in his mind well obviously as some kind
of a [ __ ] high adventure seduction
like you know I'm like back in the
medieval air era where you abducted your
wife you know something they have some
cultures that still do that you know
like you're something out of Pirates of
Penzance love me
yeah like something out of Pirates of
Penzance or some weird [ __ ] like that
you know yeah that's [ __ ] up
I think they still got down in Romania
don't they have like mock abductions of
the wife
think sometimes they still do mock ones
and yeah sure sure I don't know if they
do it for real and God not going to
Western girls anyway you know it's kind
of like eloping that's what I'm gonna
climb in your window
this guy this guy has a high opinion of
himself he he thinks that this is semi
consensual yeah oh yeah this is I'm
gonna come swinging in like Errol Flynn
on a Down broken with my sword and knife
and you're coming with me girl and it's
gonna be romantic and yeah it's not your
fault
I'm gonna take the blame for all this
wasn't that didn't we have a good time
in here I gave I'm giving you back
that's how magnanimous I am you know
yeah that's that's what this guy's
thinking man that's probably exactly
it's just like that guy who raped that
girl and then she asked for the phone uh
pretty good and he gave it to her - yeah
what a [ __ ] I hope you're out there
you're [ __ ] well a lot of serial your
phone a lot of [ __ ] well these a lot of
these serial rapists think that rape is
a woman's fantasy and it's kind of like
he's fulfilling this fantasy for them
yeah and that's what that's what keeps
him going
yeah I mean he's justifying his own need
to rape he's winded yeah I know this is
what I said and I think I said this a
couple shows ago it's like dudes brains
may in they're just like all men are
like that it's not dude that type of
dude yes that mindset is very
frightening this is a psychological
problem and you don't know by looking at
him what dudes have that mindset I don't
think this is common as it used to be I
hope not I don't think so cuz [ __ ] man
yeah I already never leave madam is not
in the West you know and not in the
United States it's just it has something
to do with weird developmental problems
and and like family conflicts and
religious conflicts all kind of happened
together weird fetishes perversion
you know perversions so we have
repressed people they start become
perverted see I always thought like
repressing people is that's never a good
thing it never ends well young wrote a
lot about that yeah the more you repress
a person to make them more moral the
more immoral they become because they
hate it onto other people some things
need to be repressed like oh you know
I'm gonna you know cut open a kitty cat
when I'm - yes repress that okay normal
but that's not normal behavior it's like
as far as you know like I said I feel
like a lot of [ __ ] bad [ __ ] happened
particularly with kind of necrophiliac
kind of killers and stuff like that in
the 70s because they might have been
they might have been gay or might have
been and they might have been
self-hating because their families were
so dead set against it and we're making
them feel like their very identity was
erroneous and I think that is a very
very bad thing to do to somebody
especially when they're a kid it will
[ __ ] them up forever
they will become serial I think it's
more complicated than that it's well
know yeah that's a factor though I think
a lot of it is just [ __ ] and child
abuse brain damage screwed up early
development you know it's a lot of stuff
that happens yeah it's like I said it's
it's it's quite rare you're in a they're
in a secluded environment so the
information they're getting is bad which
causes them to come to weird conclusions
I don't think that in the age of the
internet things that that situation is
this common yeah well it might not
happen in the same exact doesn't happen
in the same way it's not you know you
might have one of these weird school
shooters nowadays that seems more common
right but these weird freakazoids I
think they're kind of an enduring and
it's you think I'm running with Kukulcan
I think I think I think a lot of these
weird perverts I think they're in this
part of the world an endangered species
well I hope so either that or they're
just going further because of the
Internet
and kind of the the because you say the
moral repression isn't quite as strong I
think religion had a lot to do with that
- yeah the more that they would put
these people under these weird religious
restrictions the weirder they got I mean
I hate do is just look at some of these
churches what was going on inside some
of these churches yeah it was master
yeah we've talked we've done the shows
about that yeah we did a creepy cult
watch at that priest pimping out
schoolgirls to the cops yeah remember
that [ __ ] that well that was a the
keepers yeah watch the keepers on
Netflix and actually a lot of the murder
cases they're like sister Kathy says
Nick and I think Joyce Milwaukee and
stuff like that that's that's actually
in my new book those physik unsolved
murders but yeah so I guess we will wrap
but I like doing true crime though
because I find it really interesting but
it is always kind of fun yeah I see this
guy you know we gotta leave this one the
same way we left original Night Stalker
at the time that we first at the time we
did but wouldn't it be awesome he's
either dead or he's still out there and
an old man not doing it anymore
we find him but would it be also if they
caught this douche that would be awesome
yeah but I don't think they will
probably not but it would be awesome
gonna be awesome if we got to do an
update on this he's not a typical
criminal if he's alive he's not
committing crimes right now which means
that there's no reason neither did the
Golden State killer but they eventually
caught his cranky they triangulated him
again alright so we are gonna wrap up
episode 106 remember if you like the
show to like share subscribe on all your
social media and share with all your
friends tell everybody about us it helps
us grow bigger and if you'd like to
financially support the show you can go
to our patreon page at patreon.com slash
13 o'clock podcast or you can go to our
blog which is 13 o'clock podcast
wordpress.com and there's a link in the
sidebar to a PayPal account also make
sure to check out our zazzle stores as
well comm / 13 o'clock where you have a
bunch of different t-shirts and a tote
bag and I'm gonna probably be adding
some more t-shirts at some point in the
future also check out our latest movie
review which was a Clockwork Orange if
you haven't seen it already and go
subscribe to us on bit suit vo and
dailymotion if you would it really
helped
without a lot and that will do it for
this installment we will see you next
time bye
introduced to you
Nagato mystical
about you see you what you do
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]